and here's another thing about you is
that you you disappear a lot yeah well
yeah you know it's good way not to get
on peoples nerves but you guys are
always around you're irritating I mean
I'll blow some smoke up your ass I told
you I did that at that Israel tour in
December and I took my 80 year old Jesus
Freak mother with me to Jerusalem Wow if
I wasn't the favorite child before so
yeah we went over a week early and and
you know we took her saw the sights and
you know where Jesus was crucified and
all that good happy stuff yeah and so
then the tour started and we were and I
shared a hotel room with my mother for
two weeks
watch yeah which was pretty christ-like
I have to say what is that like uh well
I mean it was good I loved my mom you
know ours and it was kind of it was cute
like I did when the tour started
she'd wait up and talk to me about it
and everything but so we were watching
television in Tel Aviv and that Sasha
Baron Cohen movie The Dictator was on
yeah and you're in it yeah hilarious
uh-huh I watched it with my mother
we're like in the two beds you know
she's on her bed I'm in my bed and we're
watching this and we're both laughing
our asses off yeah I was like I got a
friend of mine I said she said really
that's what I'm saying
yeah really great memory oh cool
that's a weird watching that watching
you be funny was my mom and Tel Aviv's
that's kind of memory it's cool that
you're there with her and also that slab
I went there to you're up there with
Jesus getting crucified as well until
yeah wait that place where they scope
were they he was crucified how do they
know that because I went there to I've
been in that spot too how did you know
that that's the spot where he was
crucified I you know hey do they know
for sure no of course not I don't know
but yeah it's the Church of the Holy
Sepulchre well that's what it's called
that's the church that they built around
the spot and then there's the
like dig well it's it's like there's a
couple spots in that church where it's
like no way that they were that close to
each other yeah no we were in a room in
Jerusalem and they're like and I still
did but cigarette I told the story
before misty burn right yeah was soothe
burn I lit up a cigarette cuz I don't
know where the [ __ ] were and the guy was
like can you to the you know smoke
outside of this building cuz this is the
word that last supper was right and I go
I'm passing it I go okay sorry man like
but in my head I'm like how the [ __ ] do
they know that this is worth spawners
but I guess they know maybe there's
crumbs left over from the dinner you
smoked in that room I was in that room
really yeah I just walk in that room no
I'm sure the apostles smoked right thank
you with that yeah yeah with goat weed
or what are they smoking says incense
incense all the time what do you what do
you think frankincense was it was a bag
so you're defending Funkadelic face here
yeah
we're not used to decent people and yeah
yeah you're blowing my mind right now
music he's a good dude that's why I'm
saying yeah you're a decent man Jesus
[Music]